we want to make AI technology for image
analysis easily accessible for
enterprises so we created cloud auto I'm
a low vision currently to perform image
analysis on Google cloud platform
developers can use the vision API to
access a pre trained model or design and
train a custom model with cloud machine
learning engine let's say you're a
meteorologist and want to train a model
to identify different types of clouds
like cumulus cumulonimbus or Stratus to
predict upcoming weather patterns or
flight plans if you tried this with the
vision API here are the labels you'd get
back
it wasn't trained specifically to
identify different types of clouds what
if you want to train a model to classify
images specific to your dataset without
writing model code cloud auto ml vision
lets businesses and developers with
limited machine learning expertise train
custom vision models for their own use
cases developers can upload their own
labelled or unlabeled data set train and
manage their models and use those models
directly from the cloud to make
predictions let's take a look at the
auto ml you I begin by uploading your
images to cloud auto ml then press the
train button to train a custom model on
your image data set when training
completes analysis and stats of the
model quality are available directly in
the auto ml UI next use your model to
generate a prediction on new data either
in the UI or with a simple REST API call
[Music]
this process is easy from start to
finish simply upload your data and cloud
Auto ml vision will handle scalably
training and serving the high-quality
model you can learn more here